star trek picard fans got a preview of
what the future holds in the final
frontier thanks to a teaser video for
the series second
season on paramount plus here are all
the small details you missed and the new
teaser for star trek picard season 2.
it makes every bit of sense that
jean-luc picard would have a painting of
his old ship the enterprise d
hanging up in his chateau it's the ship
where fans of tng spent the most time
from the first episode of the series to
its unceremonious
end in the third act of star trek
generations from its oblong angles to
its amtrak
interiors it became the imaginary second
home to a generation of nerds
the cool detail here is that the
painting on display isn't a new addition
it's the same one that picard had
hanging in the ready room of the
enterprise during
the tv years complete with its late 80s
semi-velvet aesthetic
there are definitely some questions left
hanging in the air by its inclusion in
picard how it survived the crash when
the ship's disk hit the ground for
example and which of the salvage guys
thought i should grab this
framed print on the way out will these
questions be answered
no probably not but nice to see a
familiar artifact from the old days
anyway
20 seconds into the teaser there's a
subtle reminder that books still exist
in the 24th century the meat of the shop
belongs to a copy of paradise lost but
if you let your eyes wander to the right
side of the screen you'll notice that
picard may have been using his
collection of classic literature to
cover up the fact that he never outgrew
noir dime novels underneath the works of
milton the good captain has a copy of
dixon hill in the long dark tunnel
one of the depression era mysteries that
picard used to love escaping into via
the holodeck the enterprise's answer to
the question
what if your super nintendo tried to
kill you one out of five times you
turned it on
dixon hill episodes were a highlight of
star trek the next generation with
picard letting his hair down for
lack of a better word and getting into a
fantasy world where he played the
private detective
dixon hill details being everything the
cover seen in the teaser trailer even
features the name of the author
tracy tormey itself a reference to the
longtime star trek writer of the same
name
right around the 25 second mark of
picard's season 2 teaser you'll notice a
gilded model ship
pedestrian nerds will recognize it as
not the enterprise
old heads though know it as the
stargazer see back in the days before
picard landed the flagship of the
federation he was stationed aboard a
rinky-dink vessel
ncc 2893 a constellation-class ship with
a chip on its shoulder
it was an overworked underpowered vessel
always on the verge of flying apart of
the seams jean luc was still relatively
small potatoes at the time serving as a
helmsman but
fate threw him a bone in the form of his
captain's sudden death picard took
command
saving the day and making a name for
himself to the point where starfleet
promoted him
making him the captain of the stargazer
he served as the ship's captain for over
two decades
the stargazer story could fit nicely
with the narrative being set up in the
teaser trailer which seems focused on
old regrets resurfacing as time presses
on
picard eventually lost the ship during a
battle with the ferengi and wound up
court-martialed for it whatever the case
he's always kept that first command
close to his heart we even saw a model
of the ship in his section of the
starfleet archive museum during season 1
of picard
the clearest overarching theme of the
teaser is the concept of time
and the most literal allusion to that
concept comes in the form of an
hourglass on picard's desk
as the camera pans up the device the
sands inside move backward
sliding up into the top of the glass
instead of down toward the bottom
this obviously suggests the turning back
or reversing of time
something that picard's narration speaks
to but it also might have a much more
specific meaning for picard himself
fans of star trek the next generation
may remember that the series finale all
good things
saw picard being transported through
three different time periods his past
his present and his future as he tries
to get to the bottom of a spatial
anomaly that poses a potential threat to
humanity
as if that wasn't enough the mischievous
omniscient being
q appears to him apparently to toy with
him but ultimately guiding his mission
it's the last time that picard and q met
as far as we know although the hourglass
has some general symbolic meaning it may
also be directly referencing that
specific mission which saw picard going
back and forth through time like the
sand and the hourglass
that feels even more likely when you
consider that the next image in the
teaser
is a clear and direct reference to q out
of all the tng characters that fans were
hoping to see in season one of picard
one stood out like a mariachi band on
the bridge of the enterprise d
and that's q
he's back this strange cosmic figure was
intertwined with the plot of star trek
the next generation from its very first
episode
debuting in encounter at far point q is
a member of a race of omnipotent space
gods
also called q it's complicated
throughout the series q would appear to
antagonize picard and crew on whom he
developed a curious fixation
episodes in which he appeared were
always memorable from the time he turned
the enterprise's command crew into
characters from robin hood to the much
more serious encounter in which he
warned the enterprise about the looming
threat of the borg
all of this he claimed was part of a
great trial to see if the human race was
worthy of existence
the trial never ended captain we never
reached a verdict
but now we have you're guilty
whether he's back to his old tricks
remains to be seen but like he pointed
out in the series finale and once again
now in picard's season 2 teaser
the trial never ends check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you